[Applause]
so today apple announced their
self-service repair program and a pretty
major flip on their stance on right to
repair and yes there is still a bit of a
catch but my first reaction one seeing
this was
well i ain't never ever seen you act
like this before it does seem kind of
crazy we're seeing them like add ports
back to the macbook pro going back on
that stuff and now flipping a stance on
the right to repair but my second
reaction was
why so i made a video a little while
back this year all about right to repair
that i highly suggest watching talks
about the concept a bunch of companies
with various stances around the issue
and why it's important the concept of
being able to repair the thing that you
bought should be very simple but in 2021
it's not now apple isn't the only
company guilty of various bad practices
like this but
they are one of the most influential
consumer facing companies
ever right so any step they make in
favor of right to repair
is a pretty major deal so here's the
announcement they've made and i'll link
it below apple announced the
self-service repair program which allows
customers who are comfortable with
completing their own repairs access to
apple's genuine parts and tools this is
starting with the iphone 12 and 13
lineups starting early next year and
soon we'll add m1 max after that and the
initial phase of this program will focus
on the most commonly serviced modules
such as iphone's display
battery and camera so basically
independent certified repair shops have
had access to some tools and parts for
some very basic repairs to stuff like
the iphone and now individuals
like you and me will be added to the
list of people who can get access to
those tools and parts
that's the pretty big deal so let's say
you drop your iphone or something on the
ground the screen cracks okay you've
already always had the option to go to
the apple store and have them do it for
that price or you could take it to an
independent repair shop and pay for them
to do it but now you have the extra
option if you're a confident and
competent enough person
to get that manual get those individual
parts straight from apple and do the
repair yourself and then you can
actually send back the old or broken
parts to apple so they can recycle them
and then you'll get a credit back on
your account for some of that value
that's not bad so i on the surface
i think this is great i think it's huge
the the potential e-waste being removed
the potential repairs that have been
unlocked the real choice that's being
offered to us
and the potential ripples this sends
throughout the industry are all great
but
it's definitely it's definitely still a
first step and here's why i say that so
number one it's still the pretty simple
fairly short list so this goes back to
the point i made in the original right
to repair video which is that devices
like these phones and laptops are more
complex than ever and are built way more
tightly integrated than ever which makes
them much more difficult to repair so
even if an individual like you or me now
has the instructions and the parts
officially from apple uh some of the
deeper repairs like parts of the
motherboard like i could do a battery or
a screen no problem but you know some of
the memory might be going wrong and you
want to replace some of that it's all
still soldered together and it's
integrated so much that you'd probably
have to replace the whole thing so that
hasn't really changed now i will say i
have seen some tear downs of the new 14
and 16 inch macbook pros and the battery
looks noticeably more repair friendly
there's pull tabs under some of the
cells now only a few screws to get
inside the bottom so this does appear to
be premeditated at least a little bit
but i still don't see people like you
and i taking parts of the motherboard
off but then number two this is also
something that a lot of independent
repair shops and people like lewis
rossman have already aired their
grievances about which is that the list
of those repairs that are being
supported by apple is still so short
it's like battery screen cameras
that's it and if it's anything outside
of that there still will not be official
apple documentation or ports parts made
available
that also has not changed now the fact
is
most iphone repairs will be under those
like three most common ones i mean
screens and batteries got to be number
one and number two apparently that's
over 200 parts and tools already being
made available just for those big three
macs being added to the list will add a
lot more and those are probably the only
types of repairs i would personally at
this moment be trying to do myself but
for repairs beyond that
ports
buttons
speakers and mics and things like that i
would like independent repair shops to
be able to fix those things with
official apple parts and documentation
as well apple says the program will be
expanding later next year but as of
right now
that has also not changed so why did
apple do this i mean they've been
they've been notoriously against pretty
much any right to repair stance for
forever and this is so unlike them
well number one i think a lot of the
impending legislation
caused by the right to repair movement
has put pressure on them like there's
you know ftc
regulation coming down there's also
things in europe in law that have sort
of pressured apple and they're sort of
getting out ahead of it even a
presidential order has gone through in
the u.s i think it needs a lot more work
to be stronger but apple's seeing all
this stuff and is getting out ahead of
it a little bit but also number two
this is fantastic pr like this is a this
is a great headline especially for apple
now again a lot of the stuff still
unchanged we have a lot of questions we
don't know prices yet how much these
parts are going to cost for individuals
we don't know the qualifications if
everyone's going to be able to get these
parts or not and there's still a bunch
more details of the program that have
yet to be unveiled when it does start
next year
but
it's a great first step i will
absolutely give them that it's a great
first step and since it's a great first
step for apple one of the biggest
companies out there
it's a great first step for the industry
as a whole
so i like it but yeah this is great i
almost want to like take a broken iphone
and just repair it just for the hell of
it uh but i'm curious what you guys
think i don't know it feels like a new
look apple whether it's just them
getting out in front of legislation and
potential problems in the future or
maybe a little bit of them is also
listening to what people are saying
i don't know either way it got us here
so it's a good day for the beginning of
the movement either way that's been it
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one
peace